idea that the uk government through an
agency called
ofcom can investigate and intimidate tv
presenters for merely expressing
opinions
well that's terrifying but what's even
more terrifying is that the american
left is
absolutely envious of wielding this kind
of power
now this isn't speculation just last
month house democrats featured a
so-called journalism professor
spouting anti-american nonsense
i think you can apply some pressure
hopefully to the
uh platform companies to allow much
greater auditing we think what public
broadcasting is in the digital age
there has to be a will among the
political elite and the media elite
and the technology elite to actually
kind of do the right thing
joining me now is missouri senator josh
hawley uh senator
now the right is mocked for being
concerned
about this but this is
crazy i mean there is clearly a desire
on the part of the so-called liberal
elite class
to regulate speech and demonize those
with whom they disagree
well and they have the ability to do it
now laura i mean you look at our country
we don't have the regulatory body that
they have in the uk but we have big tech
and it's the same thing i mean big tech
is in league with the liberals with the
democrats
it's the big tech big government
alliance and big tech basically does
whatever the liberals want i mean in
some ways it's even more efficient
because it's the private sector
but you see tech bending to the will of
their liberal masters in washington you
see them
heck they censored the sitting president
of the united states just a few weeks
ago
so that is and donald trump that is so
that is
what tech is doing and they're doing
everything that the uk regulatory
authority is i mean this
this new age of censorship is upon us
yeah i mean they used to make uh
make fun of uh my old book shut up and
sing say how could you say shut up and
sing
but they're literally canceling
the former president of the united
states on one of the biggest
social media platforms in the world i
mean we forget about that that
you mean i might not like them but the
fact that the former president
still cannot post on twitter it's
shameful
and he was and he was the sitting
president at the time i mean
at the time twitter facebook instagram
these did all these platforms
the sitting president of the united
states and as you say lord they've
extended their ban and they've done that
to many other
conservatives whether they're throttling
down the circulation of their posts or
their stories news stories for
journalists that did it to the new york
post of course or whether just outright
d platforming them
and this goes back to the left loves the
big corporations the left loves big tech
they love this corporate power they love
it because they can control it
this is the big story of our time is
that the left and the corporate
the big corporate power are in league
together and that's how they intend to
basically
exert social control over the country
and this is why conservatives have to
stand up and say whoa whoa
whoa first of all we're we're not going
to roll over and let you destroy the
first amendment and secondly whatever
happened
to free and fair competition in tech in
every other sector and this is why we
need to break these
businesses up yeah well it should have
been done when the republicans had the
house and the senate but they were all
married to big tech as well or
or hoping to be senator today you wrote
a letter to president biden
saying in part that there's a crisis on
the southern borders full-blown
emergency
i urge you to immediately send
department of dhs secretary alejandro
mayorkas
to congress to testify to the senate
homeland security governmental affairs
committee
senator what do you expect to get from
him i mean he's obviously
in agreement that this is an evolving
situation
to challenge but it's not a crisis yeah
we can't use that word crisis
meanwhile we've got the border
encounters that's what the border patrol
calls
when they apprehend somebody at the
border it tripled this month laura than
it was a year ago this time
triple now there's been a big change
between last year and this year and that
changes joe biden
and what we're seeing is this
administration's policies
are acting as a magnet and they are
creating a full-blown
humanitarian crisis at the border
trafficking is up through the roof
it is through the roof the exploitation
of children and this administration's
doing nothing they're looking the other
way and as you say
president he won't even have a news
conference i mean he won't answer any
questions at all the least he can do
is actually send his administration
chiefs to capitol hill
and make them answer questions what are
they going to do about this crisis
and just looking the other way is not a
policy you've been watching
president biden over the last few weeks
are you concerned about his
mental competence and watching the way
he's dealing with reporters or not
dealing with them
you know i'm really concerned about the
fact that he won't answer questions i
mean i just think it is it is senator
you're looking at them you've been
around older people we all have been
we've all had aging parents
are you concerned yeah i i think that
the fact laura
that this is a guy who is the president
of the united states
and he apparently cannot have a single
media availability where he is not
staffed
with with handlers who will let him
answer a single
unplanned question and let alone to
actually have a real press conference
that is very telling and it's very
concerning
and it extends all the way through his
administration so yeah i am concerned
i'm concerned about their policy
direction i'm concerned what they're
doing at the border and i'm concerned
about his ability
to answer questions and actually provide
leadership i mean it's time for him to
answer some tough questions and to
actually show he's ready to do this job
and take care of the border among many
other things
senator great to see you tonight thank
you so much thank you